hello in this video i explain to you
the connections and the
differences between the correlation of
the degression and covers causality and
with that we start again from
my video about the correlation points
and he looks for the correlation
analysis the connection of variables could be a question
there is one  connection between the
age at which a child speaks the first sentences
and later school success the
correlation analysis shows that two
characteristics are connected. it can now
be examined whether one variable can be used
to predict the other variable
child speaks the first sentences
can be predicted with a regression is there a correlation between the
age at which a child speaks the first sentences
himself and later success
at school, in this case one can
even speak of a causal relationship
, i.e. that the age at which a
child d  speaking the first
sentences influences later school success in
this case it is so easy because we have
a temporal separation it is
clear that later school success
cannot influence the age at which he speaks the
first sentences
but attention that is not always so
easy  may we have a look at the
next example let's say at the end
of school you do
an intelligence test with students and ask them for
their Abitur grades after you
have done your survey and analyzed the data
it will certainly
emerge that there is a correlation between intelligence and
Abitur grades  there is but
now the big question mark is
there a causal relationship
how easy it is to set up a recession model
and define intelligence as an
independent variable and
predict the high school grade as a dependent variable and
thus the high school grade with intelligence
but we have not yet
proven causality, which means  now  n
causality causality means that
there is a clear
cause and effect relationship between two variables
a common mistake in the
interpretation of statistics is that
if there is a correlation there is
causality here I have a
suitable example from the textbook
textbook statistics by rainer leonhardt
find the link  du in the video
description the american
statistician on it found
a
negative correlation between the number
of head lice and the body temperature of the inhabitants of
an archipelago a negative correlation means that
people with many people
generally have a lower
body temperature than people
with fewer houses the inhabitants of the
archipelago  have
drawn the conclusion that lice because they lower the fever are
good for health
so that means that lice have an influence on the
body temperature is
actually the causal relationship
but exactly the other way around in an
experiment k  it can be proven
that a high fever drives away the lice
the high temperature is the cause
not the effect
that is why one should never speak of a
causal relationship just because there is
a correlation
there are precise
prerequisites for causality but what are the
prerequisites for causality
from  when can one
speak of a kazakh relationship
there are two prerequisites for causality firstly there
is a
significant connection i.e. a significant correlation this
prerequisite is of course easy to
check the coalition coefficient is simply
used and checked whether it
differs significantly from 0
the second  requirement can be met in two
ways
first is met if there is a chronological
order of the variables, i.e. if the variable is
measured in advance
lippi i can also meet the second
requirement if a
theoretically sound and plausible
theory is available  Egt in which direction the
causal relationship goes, neither of the
two should apply, so there is neither
a chronological order nor can
causality be based on a well-founded theory
, one can only
speak of a connection,
but never about causality, so it cannot be
said that variables are
influenced  have b or the other way around
let's take a look at our
two examples again
in the first example where the
question is whether the age at which a
child speaks the first
sentences influences later school success
how clearly a temporal
component can be the other way around the relationship  not
be if you have a great school success through a lot of tutoring
this of course has no influence if
you have spoken the first sentences on
the other hand if we
measure the intelligence and
query the Abitur average at the same time we do not have this
time component so that we
can make a selection here  it has to be able to hit
give a well-founded theory which
variable influences which
does not exist no statement can be made as to who the
causality
is there is certainly a high correlation
between intelligence and high school graduation
but it could also be that people
who study a lot have good grades
and
have acquired knowledge accordingly  in order to
do well in an intelligence
test i.e. the intelligence and the school grade
are determined at the same time
this can of course be avoided by
taking the intelligence test before the start of
school then you can
be sure that the school cannot have had any
influence on the intelligence test
this is of course with  a lot of effort
involved because you only get the results
many years later and you don't have to ask the
same person at two different
times. now you've got a good overview of
what causality means and we
can go into the recession more
precisely  Next watch here for my video
on simple and multiple line
regression which I look forward
to seeing again soon